science has new frontiers we should work
in science we improve airs all over the
world
you
of course it IV for me was not only a
discovery of the virus but also what we
can do for Humanity for population all
over the world
vallah laureates here I believe there
are only three women and one is actually
authorized agency to discover the link
between HIV and AIDS we we love to face
a global scale epidemic for to patients
starting treatment there is five new
case of infection and still there is 2.7
million new cases of infection per year
today we are I'm very inspired
personally by her career how she manages
to juggle her personal life and her
career as a woman how she has managed to
overcome a lot of the stigmas that are
associated with her research
the work that you did was done in a
climate that was somewhat controversial
because at least in the United States
hiv/aids appeared first in the
homosexual population seen two days
that's remained from time to time when
I'm taking a taxi in France so in other
countries you know how taxi drivers are
they asked what are you working on and
so on and I said working any trivia and
to say you cannot be enjoy study know
the disease and instead of spending your
time and spending money on those people
include the taxi driver because nobody
is not at risk for HIV any agree with
you and it's exactly what they said
right
and I finished by saying look is by is
this kind of behavioral reaction that
you have that the infection is pretty
right and what about the information
that is sometimes misconstrued
especially in third-world Nations where
people don't even know that by being
exposed to certain body fluids you can
or cannot get aids or different
hypotheses on how to cure AIDS or
prevent AIDS how do you approach those
topics education let's take the case of
Uganda it has been clearly shown that
when the local community started to be
more after why we saw the prevalence of
infection reduced by 50% so we know it
can work
my approach personally when I go for the
first time in the country it's just to
listen to talk with communities even to
go to the markets you know and meet the
population and just try to understand so
you're saying that basically there won't
be one solution for for everybody
exactly they don't
now you feel but even in our own country
there is diverse situation in Washington
DC for example the prevalence of
infection is very high three percent
it's ironic isn't it that the nation's
cannibals I mean San Diego would have
one of the highest infection rates right
and it's supposed to be the the heart of
the country how you explain this kind of
see tonight I don't know how it explain
it but growing up in in Canada myself
one of the biggest culture shocks I saw
was moving to a country where universal
health care was not available to
everybody and I think that's also very
expensive because people not only lack
access to treatment but they lack access
to information and in the end that hurts
us because you have more cases of for
example HIV AIDS in populations that
don't have access to health care and in
turn that makes our country a more
dangerous place vanilla both yeah I'm
also Bolivian which is a developing
nation and I gave a scientific talk
there a few years ago but also that's a
population that's very religious and so
how would you approach talking about
hiv/aids condom use safe sex in a
population that supposedly
doesn't ever have sex outside of a
monogamous marriage my advice is to
start to have exchanges and discussion
with the younger generation because they
are the future and is through them that
we can change the situation and you
wrote you wrote a letter right to the
Pope that's right
what was the the content of that letter
what motivated you to do something like
that
the Pope make a statement saying that
condom were not efficient to prevent
against HIV and we have to stop this
kind of statement I mean it's criminal
he's destroying in few minutes all the
work done by others what about
abstinence only education and the types
of influences that that has on the
spread of hiv/aids I mean this is not
serious
do you think really that it possible for
you life to follow absolutely it's okay
for a while but
the day of my wedding I was in the lab
I receive a phone call from who became
my husband at 11:30 in the morning
saying do you think you will come you
mentioned that you were in the lab on
your on your wedding day
and that your your fiance had to call
you to remind you to go to the church do
you think that that event symbolizes
what your career has been like very
science focus totally what advice do you
have for women who are trying to pursue
careers in science in the midst of a you
know social climate that's still
somewhat male-dominated and where women
still have roles that are expected to be
fulfilled sit legs or right bone I
selected the right partner because he
had a lot of humor it wasn't surprising
situation he knew me very well I knew
where I was of course and he knew that
if you marry me all his life with Jesus
have you faced discrimination for being
a woman in a male-dominated field yeah
yeah especially in the my youngest year
it's a did you have role models that
sort of helped push you along few
people's I've been models what about you
do you have mothers my my mom's an
engineer and just the fact that she
started in La Paz Bolivia and really had
to work hard to get to where she is now
is inspiration because I started you
know she started here and I'm starting
here so I have an obligation almost to
to pursue my dream because it's almost
like she did that for me my mother was
was not working she was at home and my
father it's it's amongst these kind of
people you know that seeing that woman
should stay at home
for me it was a pressure and certainly I
told my father not so long ago thank you
thank you very much because of your
behavior regarding women I said to
myself when I was young I'm going to
show you what a woman is capable to do
however I'm not a feminist myself I
think it's nice to go to equity in
condition that we keep as a criteria
excellencies if we are just taking woman
because the woman I'm not satisfied
personally at all I I agree because
that's the same as saying I won't take
you because you're a man
I do see more women in science these
days yet right now I'm the only female
in my lab and the only female it's a
physics lab yes and so in general some
areas still do have a large discrepancy
is what I found out yeah because in
biomedical research she's very
personable and very open with with the
answers especially about her personal
life and it was very inspiring to hear
that she basically got to the point
where she is on her own motivation
also we talk about women in science of
course our own experience young
experience compared to my old experience
young scientists like Mackey special
field physics where is a very few women
I would say just be persistent to show
them that women in your field I think
that once I go back to Illinois back to
my lab costs pauses message will will be
one of motivation and one of really
perseverance in my field regardless of
barriers and I intend to think back on
this conversation whenever I'm feeling
disappointed about lab results or
whenever I feel a little bit alone as a
woman in science and just try to push
severe through this obstacle
Oh